we could hardly compiled a list of
2015's best PC games without mentioning
The Witcher 3 Wild Hunt a title which
sets a new benchmark for fantasy action
rpgs fastness and longevity are not
always desirable qualities in their own
right but in this case the story of
supernatural contract killer Geralt of
Rivia spans more than a hundred hours
and so much of it will linger in your
memory your journey across the immense
northern kingdoms involves genuinely
interesting characters memorable
locations major plot decisions a fall on
your shoulders and awe-inspiring
monsters to free from the earth it's the
attention to detail the sharp writing
the vivid characters and the epic
heroics that make every hour enjoyable
we'll be foolish not to mention rocket
League as well as it's clearly the best
multiplayer game released this year this
is a soccer title with a perverse
ingenious twist the footballers have
been replaced by cars your shiny blocks
of metal and carbon fiber lack the
extremities required for nuanced ball
control yet you can go from zero to 60
in a couple of seconds the result is a
masterfully berserk depiction of the
beautiful game with players tumbling
across stadiums boosting their thrusters
skyward flipping and twisting their roll
cages with a bloodthirsty desire to
collide with a giant beach ball while
this chaotic spin on soccer seems like
an awful idea on paper in practice it's
an elegant masterpiece eliciting an
explosion of emotion in its players
Metal Gear Solid 5 the phantom pain
represents a change in direction that
Konami being the first in the series to
launch a day and date alongside the
console additions it also happens to be
the greatest stealth game of all time
replacing the series room by room level
structure with a vast stretch of Afghan
desert the freedom in your approach to
each mission adds a dazzling degree of
strategy and planning something that had
a natural limit in previous games the AI
which has always been excellent read the
series now has the freedom to be truly
spectacular with enemies reacting and
adapting to signs of your presence it's
by no means perfect the story's final
stretch being particularly divisive but
it's an extraordinary achievement
nonetheless
Paulette for represents another
remarkable achievement in a year packed
with acclaimed high-profile games even
for a Bethesda title the degree of
freedom offered to the player here is at
standing a whole library of side quests
can be discovered and pursued at your
convenience while instruments of death
in its bleak world can be crafted and
modified to your heart's content
dig deeper and you'll discover further
options to strengthen your armor mix
your own cans and pick out your
favorites from an extensive menu of
imaginative ability perks and then
there's the option to build entire
structures with their own electrical
circuits and farms forage from materials
you scavenged along the way fallout 4 is
fundamentally an arcade game thrusting
you into its world with little guidance
or the slick and mollycoddling of modern
triple-a games what it offers instead is
a promise that every moment of curiosity
and every creative thought you conjure
in this world will be handsomely
rewarded the fifth entrance on our list
is Kerbal space program a game that
gives you the keys to space and lets you
pick the destination from the
nail-biting first man launch to putting
the final touches on your multi module
refueling station in orbit around the
moon Kerbal space program strikes a
wonderful balance between education and
trial and error gameplay the semi real
physics model nails that sweet spot of
complexity making it accessible to
anyone with the desire to learn yet
avoiding the headache that can come with
an extremely realistic simulation when
weeks of iteration finally carries your
adorable Kerbal into the depths of space
you'll certainly feel like a rocket
scientist and when your moon landing is
just so slightly off tipping your craft
and dooming your poor kerbals you learn
another important lesson to never give
up
you